الكره لا تعرف العاطفه خيبه امل وقلوب
مكسوره دموع الخروج تضرب نجوم كاس العالم
لم يتبقى الا ميسي
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان مونديال قطر لهذا العام قد كسر
قلوب الكثيرين من نجوم كره القدم
المحبوبين الذين يراهم الجماهير على انهم
ايقونات الساحره المستديره فقد شعر الكثير
من كبار نجوم كره القدم العالميه بخيبه
امل كبيره بعد وداع منافسات المونديال
وضياع الاحلام
اول دموع كانت اللاعب لويس سواريز بعد
الخروج المخيم لمنتخب بلاده من دوري
المجموعات 3 دموع النجم البرازيلي نيمار
في وداع المونديال بعد سقوط منتخب بلاده
امام كرواتيا وضياع حلم التتويج بالكاس
السادسه لراقسي سامبا بعدها بيوم بكى
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو بحرقه بسبب
الاقصاء من الدوري ربع النهائي على يد
المغرب
[موسيقى]
وما هي الا ساعات وكان قائد المنتخب
في نفس الموقف بعد بكائه على اضاعته لركله
جزاء والهزيمه امام فرنسا واستلامه تذكره
العوده لبلاده
[موسيقى]
فيتنام الذي تخبئه الايام القليله القادمه
في مونديال قطر 2022 واي دموع سنراها
تنهمر من عيون نجوم الساحره المستديره